[Music]
how was the sex in your
like a solid relationship what the
is wrong with you
yeah right yeah right
so can you tell me a little bit about
your relationship with each other
how did you guys meet and how long were
you guys together
so we met on tinder and then we started
dating two weeks later
yep the reason why we broke up i guess
you could say
was our timing just seemed like it
wasn't a line
i wanted more of a relationship than he
wanted but we had like multiple
conversations about it where it was like
it's not likely that it's gonna work
she saw me as a best friend and i think
like it took me a year
a year and a half and i was like i see
something out of this
and that's when we dated for basically
eight years did you have breakup sex
like which time yeah i mean
yeah every time we had our break
of not talking to each other and then
when we finally started talking to each
other we did have sex
i don't remember it that way how do you
remember it i was
not having sex hmm what are you lying to
me yes yeah that's how
that's how broke up hooked up after more
than once
uh no no not yet
[Laughter]
how was the sex in your relationship
like a solid seven what the
is wrong with you yeah right yeah right
ten oh okay okay cool
nine five
at what point in the relationship
or the entire time
it fluctuated how long did it take for
you to be
physically intimate with another person
after your breakup
like it's okay you won't hurt my
feelings
uh like eight months or something like
that
it was a while until i was comfortable
eat
i yeah i would say about the same
maybe a little bit shorter i haven't
what's the next question i mean when you
have feelings for somebody
like it like it elevates it like
feelings yep
shut up wow i wanted to have sex with
somebody that i wanted to
uh get into a relationship again and so
that takes a while you know finding
somebody
i i the next day for me unfortunately
at the time it was shocking and
devastating there was other stuff that
took place before that final incident
that happened
i'm a level up type of person like i hit
my my rock bottom and then i remember
myself and i'm like oh yes
i know who i am a few months maybe maybe
a year i don't know
yeah maybe a few months a few months a
few months
i don't believe that i just wasn't
interested in anybody really for
a while for me it didn't take that long
i think the reason why i tried it with
someone else after is because i was
really
upset i felt like i could have done
things differently that wouldn't have
created that whole
months two year of not speaking to each
other
i mean i i haven't had sex with another
person
um i mean you know fooled around a
little bit with somebody but it was
definitely like the um sad and
they knew that like i had like just went
through a breakup i was like you know
i didn't know that he hooked up with
anybody so news to me
was that i said it was a hookup do you
ever still fantasize about your ex
yeah like masturbating
sometimes no yeah i think about
i think about her and uh is a very
gorgeous girl
you know yeah no
no no yeah right like i could barely
sleep with him
really no no never
she talks way too much no i wouldn't say
a fantasy
we like we live with each other so yeah
if you know i check her out a lot though
wow i thought i was getting my feelings
hurt
fantasize is a strong word
[Music]
i mean okay i mean
yeah yeah yes absolutely
absolutely definitely most definitely
she's hot
do you compare your current partners to
your ex i don't have any current
partners
to compare to though no but when i'm
like hitting on other girls and stuff
it's
kind of feels like a waste of time just
kind of reminds me of like
what i have back at home i mean yeah i
haven't
had any i'm sure i will you know i guess
you kind of always
do think about it and he was like my
best friend too so
that is a big thing for me you know she
wasn't the
problem in the relationship it was just
the relationship you know so it's like i
like always get like trying to find that
connection again
i try not to compare like every every
one
to her we knew each other for so long
that we knew
each other like inside and out i just
know what i want now
you just know everything never mind i
shouldn't say that but yeah it's just
very different like
i still compare her to this day like
great yeah great to know
uh what was something your partner did
in bed that you hated
give me this
i think it was just mainly used in
experience it's actually really like i
didn't like the position you were in
to be honest you were inexperienced too
yeah because it was your first time but
other than that
what we learned from was like you know
like porn or whatever i didn't watch
porn going yet all right i didn't either
honestly it's never there's never been
anything where i'm like
never even just had an awkward moment in
general now i know more like what i like
to
yeah so stuff like that i love like
maybe just like a smidge more variety
yeah yeah no totally because i would be
you know get home from work late and be
tired and be like okay like
she'll try to rub me in my area
i don't know why her hand literally just
like travels like just goes to different
spots i'm like you're not at the right
to stay
right here well so like as lesbians we
use a strap-on
and when there's like a preparation
period she sometimes will
like break character but sometimes i
wish i know
i don't think she uh likes to
uh give oral for a long period of
a long period of time this guy takes a
long time and i'm tired you know
can i like can i be really really hot
this morning cool yeah
do it he likes eating a lot but it's not
something that i always
want like can we chill
can
[Laughter]
you still feel bonded to the other
person because of your sexual
history i don't feel bothered because of
her sexual history i just feel bonded
because
we had history you know because like you
know we went through like
high school together no i feel more
bonded to her because actually just like
that's
like a little soul tie right there but
yeah yeah it was my it was my first like
i was a virgin and i think
we kind of taught each other you know
there's things that i liked and then i
told her and then there's things she
liked she told me
i just never had anything good before
him
honestly uh so i think for me it was
like
pretty high oh he's not going to answer
that
oh no you just he doesn't use that word
just read it
you still have love for each other
we don't use that word we apparently
when i'm drunk i do
i mean it's just hard for me like to do
that in general like that's not a word i
like i use often or anything so i just
wasn't quite at a point where i used it
we just don't not like each other we're
still just like cool like oh she's a
cool ass person like she likes me
like yeah obviously yeah i love this
girl
a lot i think she loves me too you're
flirting a lot today
yeah we still have a lot of love for
each other we definitely feel lucky in
that
aspect you know it's not always that you
get to have that with your ex so
like i mean definitely i've learned so
much from you like you know about myself
about relationships about sex like about
like everything
i mean maybe like friendship wise yeah
when we're friends
no we can't no did you shake your head
no no we're not friends we can totally
be friends
so this is why this is why we never did
again because we like know each other
way too well now it hurts it hits a
point where i could never
what are the chances of like a
reconciliation or getting that together
definitely i'm just like she's one so
we've had talks about this where we need
to work a lot of stuff
and it just never clicked me until like
we broke up but i think the
underlying flaw was that we didn't know
how to love each other
in a relationship like we knew how to
love each other as best friends
so i think this is actually pretty great
because we're gonna talk about it like
later today
i don't wanna have to focus on anybody
but
my baby and myself right now there's a
couple things that
i know that he wants to deal with and
that i want to deal with like personally
it's on the table to the side to the
yeah way to the side
to the back
you